The Art Institute of Chicago is now launching an interactive experience...
...with the help of Airbnb.
You can live like Vincent Van Gogh, but you get to keep your ears.
But if scenes simply isn't enough, you can also spend the night.
It's like jumping into a painting.
It is, look!
Van Gogh's 1888 bedroom painting was recreated and made available to everyone on Airbnb,...
...the perfect platform to immerse yourself into the life of your host.
It's already sold out for this month,...
...but there's always next month.
Good luck scoring a night in that room.
The first block of nights sold out in five minutes,...
...and the guests who got in were thrilled.
Within one week, the story was covered in over 100 countries.
The room not only let people inside Van Gogh's art,...
...it also told the world that Van Gogh's bedrooms...
...had come to the Art Institute of Chicago...
...as thousands of people let themselves into Van Gogh's bedroom.